there are no facts only interpretations
life is not a problem to be solved but a
reality to be experienced if you are
lonely when you are alone you're in bad
company
you will never be happy if you continue
to search for what happiness consists of
you will never live if you are looking
for the meaning of life if you would be
a real seeker after truth it is
necessary that at least once in your
life you doubt as far as possible all
things
you are an aperture through which the
universe is looking at and exploring
itself we are like butterflies who
flutter for a day and think it is
forever
the cost of sanity in this society is a
certain level of alienation
there is nothing Noble in being superior
to your fellow man true nobility is
being superior to your former self we
are all in the gutter but some of us are
looking at the Stars
every man takes the limits of his own
field of vision for the limits of the
world
two things are infinite the universe and
human stupidity and I'm not sure about
the universe a great man is always
willing to be little if people never did
silly things
nothing intelligent would ever get done
when I let go of what I am I become what
I might be
[Music]
you